welcome to numpy my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com get certified
get ahead what's in it for you and we're
going to go over
what is numpy installing and importing
numpy
numpy array numpy array versus python
list
basics of numpy finding size and shape
of any array
range and arrange functions numpy string
functions
and then in part two i'll move on to
cover axes array manipulation and much
more
so let's start with what is numpy numpy
is the core library for scientific and
numerical computing in python
it provides high performance
multi-dimensional array object and tools
for working with arrays
and i'll go a step further and say there
are so many other modules
in python built on numpy so the
fundamentals of numpy are so important
to
latch on to for the python so you can
understand the other modules and
what they're doing number's main object
is a multi-dimensional array
it's a table of elements usually numbers
all of the same
type indexed by a tuple of position
integers
in numpy dimensions are called axes
take a one-dimensional array or we have
remember dimensions are also called axes
you can say this is the first axis
zero one two three four five and you can
see down here it has a shape of
six why because there's six different
elements in it in the one dimension
array
and they usually denote that as six
comma with an empty node on there
and then we have a two dimensional array
where you can see zero one two three
four five six seven and in here we have
two axes or two dimensions
and the shape is 2 4. so if you were
looking at this as a matrix or
in other mathematical functions you can
see there's all kinds of
importance on shape we're not going to
cover shape today but we will cover that
in part two
did you know that numpy's array class is
called nd
array for numpy data array now we're
going to take a detour here
because we're working in python and two
of my favorite tools
in python is the jupiter notebook and
then i like to use that sitting on top
of anaconda
and if you flip over to jupiter.org
that's
j-u-p-y-t-e-r dot org
you can go in here you can install it
off of here if you don't want to use the
anaconda notebook
but this is the jupiter setup the
documentation on the jupiter
jupiter opens up in your web browser
that's what makes it so nice is it's
portable the files are saved on your
computer
they do run in ipython or iron python
and you can create all kinds of
different environments in there which
i'll show you in just a minute
i myself like to use anaconda that's
www.anaconda.com
if you install anaconda it will install
the jupiter notebook with the anaconda
separate
and you can install jupiter notebook and
it'll run completely separate from
anaconda's jupiter notebook
and you can see here i've now opened up
my anaconda navigator
what i like about the navigator and this
is a fresh install on a new computer
which is always nice
i can launch my jupyter notebook from in
here i can bring other tools
so the anaconda does a lot more and
under environments i only have the one
environment
and i can open up the terminal specific
to this environment this one happens to
have python37 in it the most current
version as of this tutorial
and the open terminal if you're going to
do your pip installs
and stuff like that for different
modules you can also
create different environments in here so
maybe you need a python36 python35
you can see we're having a nice
framework like anaconda really helps
so you don't have to track that on your
own in the jupyter notebook and your
different jupyter notebook setups
we'll go ahead and launch this jupyter
notebook and then i've set my browser
window for a default of chrome
so it's going to open up in chrome and
you can see here
this opens up a folder on my computer we
have a couple different options on here
remember i
set the environment up as python 3.7
you would install any additional modules
that aren't already installed in your
python
on this and it keeps them separate so
you do have to for each environment
install the separate modules so they
match the environment on there and in
here we have a couple things we can look
up what's running
you have your different clusters again
this is i just installed this on a new
machine
so i just have the one a couple things
in here that were run on here recently
and when we go on here is we then have
on the upper right
new and from the pull down menu you'll
see python 3
and this will open up a new window and
now we're in jupiter
python so this is a python window and
we'll just do a print
and this of course is so hello world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple
special things you have to know we're
not going to do today which is on
graphics
if you've never seen this one of the
things you can do you can also do
a equals hello world and if you just put
the a
in there now if you do a bunch of these
where you have a equals hello world b
equals goodbye world
and you put a b a and return b it'll
only run the last one
but you can see here if you put the
variable down here it will show you
what's in that variable
and that has to do with the jupiter
notebook inline coding so
that's not basic python that's just
jupiter notebook shorthand which you'll
see in a little bit
so back to our numpy numpy array versus
python list
python list being the basic list in your
python why should we use
numpy array when we have python list
well first it's fast
the numpy array has been optimized over
years and years by multiple programmers
and it's usually very quick compared to
the basic python list
setup it's convenient so has a lot of
functionality in there that's not in the
basic python list
and it also uses less memory so it's
optimized both for speed
and memory use and let's go ahead and
jump into our jupyter notebook
since we're coding best way to learn
coding is to code
just like the best way to learn how to
write is right and the best way to learn
how to cook is cook
so let's do some coding here today and
just like
any modules we have to import numpy we
almost always import it as
np that is such a standard so you'll see
that very commonly
we can just run that and now we have
access to our numpy
module inside our python and then the
most common thing of course is to go and
create a number array
and in here we can send it a regular
list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array let's do one two three to
make it simple
and then i'm just going to type in a and
we'll run this
as you can see down here the output is
an array of one two
three and we could also do print
just a reminder that this is an inline
command so that wouldn't work if you're
using a different editor
you can see that it's an array one two
three but we'll go and leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook
and just like all your other standard
arrays i can go
a of 0 which is going to be a value of
1.
of course we do a of 1. you go all the
way through this
i have one has a value of 2 in it so
whether using the numpy array or the
basic python list that's going to be the
same that should all look pretty
familiar and
be pretty straightforward remember the
first value is always
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why
we're using numpy because we went over
the slide a little bit but let's just
take a look and see what that actually
looks like
and what we want to look at is the fact
that it's fast convenient and uses less
memory
so let's take a glance at that in code
and see what that actually looks like
when we're writing it in python and what
the differences are
and to do this i'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other
modules we're going to import the time
module so we can time it
and we're going to import the system
module so that we can take a look at how
much memory it uses
and we'll go and just run those so those
are imported so we'll do
b equals oh range of one
yeah one thousand is fine and so that's
going to create a list of one thousand
zero to nine hundred ninety nine
remember it starts at zero and it stops
right at the one thousand without
actually going to the one thousand
and let's go ahead and print and we want
system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to
a thousand we'll just throw one in there
five it doesn't matter because it's
gonna
whatever integer we put in there's gonna
generate the same value because we're
looking the size of how how much memory
it stores
an integer in and then we want to have
the link of the
b that's how many integers are in there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this in a line
we'll see oops i did that wrong
comma if we multiply them together
we'll see it generates 28 000. so that's
the size we're looking at is 28
000 i believe that's bytes that sounds
about right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy and we'll go to c equals np
and this is a range so that's the numpy
command do the same
thing that we were just doing in a list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
and then once we've created the uh c
value of c for np
dot a range let's go ahead and print
and we can do that by doing c dot size
times c dot item size
and that's very similar we did before we
did get the size of
so the c size is the size of the array
and each item
size just reversed so it's the size of
an integer 5
item size is going to be the integers
and c size
let's just take a look and see what that
generates
and wow okay we got four thousand versus
twenty eight thousand
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array
and then let's go ahead and take a look
at uh speed let's do um oh let's do size
we tried this with lower values and it
would happen so fast that the npra kept
coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off so size
and let's create an l1 bulls
range of size
and we'll do an l2 i'll just set up to
the same thing it's also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on a1
equals np dot
a range size and then let's do an a
2 equals n p dot
a range we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them
but let's go ahead and just load these
up now we'll go ahead and run this so
those are all set in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that there we go so these
are now all loaded in here
and let's do a start
equals
time dot time so it's just going to look
at my clock time and see what time it is
and we'll do result equals and let's do
let's say we got an array and we're
going to
let's do some addition here x plus y
for x comma y
and and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're going to multiply
each of the individual things on here
l1 l2
there we go so that should add up each
value so l1 plus l2 each value in each
array
then we want to go ahead and print and
let's say
python list took and then we'll do
time dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops i messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go time minus the start
and we'll convert that to seconds so
we'll go uh because in milliseconds
or times one thousand and let's hit the
run
on there this is kind of fun because you
also get a view while we're doing this
of some ways to manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bed typing
there we go okay
so we'll go ahead and run this and we
can see here that the python list took
34 actually i have to go back and look
at the conversion on there but you can
see it takes roughly 0.34 of a second
and we go ahead and print the result in
here too
let's do that and we'll run that just so
you can see what the what kind of data
we're looking at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straight forward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see python list took
46
a little different time on there
depending on what um
core because i have this is on an eight
core computer so it just depends on what
core it's running on what else is
pulling on the computer at the time
and let's go back up here and do our
start time
paste that into here and this time we're
going to do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is
so straightforward this is a lot of
reason people started using numpy is
because i can add the two arrays
together by simply going a1 plus a2
it makes a lot of sense both looking at
it and it's just very
convenient remember that slide we're
looking at fast
convenient and less memory so look how
convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see and
i don't know if we don't need to print
the result again so let's just go ahead
and print
the time on here and we'll borrow this
from the top part
because i really am a lazy type
and this isn't the python list this is
the numpy list
or number array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out and
we get 2.99 so let's take a look at
these two numbers 46
versus 2.99 so we'll just round this up
to 3.
that's a huge difference that's that's
like more than 10
times faster that's like 15 times
roughly
at a quick glance i'd have to go do the
math to look at it and it's going to
vary a little bit depending on what's
running in the background the computer
obviously
so we've looked at this and if we go
back here we found out it's
much faster yes there's different going
to be different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient
easy to read and it uses less memory so
that's the core of the numpy that's why
a lot of people
base so many other modules on numpy and
why it's so widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
when we were looking at speed and size
let's dive into a little bit more into
the basic operations
and these are always nice to see i mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time
you know look things up google is your
friend we did this with the most basic
numpy
dot array or np.array and
we'll go ahead and create an array let's
do pairs
one comma two and then let's do
three comma four and if we're gonna do
that let's do five comma six
there we go and if we go ahead and take
this
and run this i can go ahead and do our a
down here so it's in line and i'll print
that out
you can see it makes a nice array for us
so we have a
and if you look at that we have three
different objects each with two values
in them
and hopefully you're starting to think
well how many dimensions
or indexes is that and you'll see three
by two
so let's go ahead and take a look and
let's go how about a dot in dimensions
speaking of which we'll run that and we
have
two dimensions for each object and then
we can do the item
size so a dot we saw this earlier
we looked up how many items it was up
here where we wanted to multiply item
size times the actual size of the object
so the memory is being used versus the
item size
and we should see four there memory is
compressed down that's always a good
thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science
and you're moving it from one format to
another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two
three rows by two objects in each one
generally i don't look too much at the
size
but the dimensions i'm always looking up
and this is nice you can automate it so
you might be converting something you
might need to know how many dimensions
are going into the
next machine learning package so that
you can automatically just have it
send that information over so we looked
at a
shape let's go and create a slightly
different array np
dot array let's go ahead and just do as
our original
setup here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do d
type equals in this case let's do
np
float 64. and so what we've done is
converting all of these into
a float and we've typed in a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values
one dot zero there's no actual zero in
there just so it's the one dot
or the one period two three period four
period five period six
period and this again data science i
don't know how many times i've had to
convert something from an integer to a
float so that's going to work correctly
in the model i'm using
so very common features to be aware of
and to be able to get around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item
size we'll go and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase
well doubling is always a big increase
in computers but it's not a huge
increase compared to what it would be if
you're running this
in the python list format and then
we did the shape earlier without having
it set to the float64 let's go ahead and
do a shape with it set to 64.
and it should be the same three comma
two so it all matches
so we've gone through and remember if
you really if this is all brand new to
you
according to the cambridge study at the
cambridge university
if you're learning a brand new word in a
foreign language
the average person has to repeat it 163
times
before it's memorized so a lot of this
you build off of it so hopefully you
don't have to
repeat it 163 times but we did manage to
repeat it at least twice here if not a
little bit more
and let's go ahead and take this we're
going to look at one more
setup on here and let me just take this
last statement here on the converting
our properties of our data and instead
of float
64 let's do complex
let's just see what that looks like and
let's go and print that out
and run it and so we now have a complex
data set up and you'll see it's denoted
by the one dot plus
zero dot j and if we flip over here and
do
a basic search for numpy data types
better to go to the original web page
but pull up a bunch of these you can see
there's a whole list of different numpy
data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64
complex 128. complex number represented
by
264 bit floats real and imaginary
components
one option on there float 16 float32
float shorthand for float 64 most
commonly used
and of course all the different ones
that you can possibly put into your
numpy array
so we covered a basic addition up there
we're comparing how fast it runs
but some very basic components how to
set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also
the shape probably one of the more used
i used
a shape all the time very commonly used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do
numpy dot
zeros and we're gonna do three comma
four there we go and we'll go ahead and
run this
and you can see if i do np dot zeros
i create a numpy array of zeros
this is really important i was
rebuilding my own neural network
and i needed to create an array where i
initialized the weights
and i want them all to be the same
weight in this case i wanted them to
start off as
zero for the particular project i was
working on and there's other options
like you can do
numpy ones and we'll do the same thing
three comma four we'll run that and you
can see i've created a an array of numpy
ones
in this case it comes out as a float
array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
python and do lrange5
and we'll print the l so as our list
and if i run that it doesn't create the
range until after the fact until you
actually execute it that's an upgrade in
python python27
actually created the array zero one two
three four
this one actually creates the script and
then once it's used it then actually
generates the array
and if we do that in numpy a range
remember that from before
and if we do a numpy a range five
and let's do uh l equals
or we can just leave it as numpy that's
fine there we go just run that
you can see there we actually get an
array zero one two three four for the
value the numpy arrange a range five
generates the actual array and for part
one we're going to do just
one more section on basic setup
and we're going to concatenation
do a concatenation now example
there we go we're going to do strings
let's take a look at strings
what's going on with there and let's do
oh let's see print let's do an np
character something new here and we're
going to
add and then here's our brackets for
what we're going to add
oh and let's say let's do
hello comma hi
and in the brackets on there let's
create another one
and this one's going to be abc
and we'll do x y z so we're just
creating something randomly making some
up on here and then we'll go ahead and
just print this
if we run that and come down here and of
course make sure all your brackets are
open and closed correctly and then
you can see in here when we concatenate
the example in
numpy it takes the two different arrays
that we set up in there and
it combines the hello with the abc and
the high with xyz
and if we can also do something like
print
oh let's do np character dot
multiply so there's a lot of different
functions in here again you can look
these up
it's probably good to look them all up
and see what they are but it's good to
also just see
them in action let's do hello space
comma
three and we'll run this one
and run that without the error you'll
see it does hello hello hello so we
multiplied it by three
and we can also let's just take this
whole thing here
instead of retyping it and we can do
character
center so instead of multiply let's do
center
and over here keep our hello going
take the space out of there and let's do
center at
20 and fill
character equals and we'll fill it with
dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side
and we keep going with that we can also
in addition to doing the fill function
we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase
we can do uppercase we can split split
line strip
join these are all the most common ones
and let's go ahead and just look at
those and see what those look like each
one of them
here we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine i always like
to say hello universe
and you can see here we did a capital h
with the world but so we want to
capitalize so capitalize is the first
one
in the array so we get hello world on
there
and we can also take this and instead of
capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how are you doing instead of
do you let's run that
and you can see here because we created
it as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have hello world all
capitalized and we have just hello
and you can see that one is an array and
one is just a string
if we run that you get a an array with
hello world lowercase and hello
lowercase
and if we're going to do it that way we
can also do it the opposite way
there's also upper and let's paste those
in there
and you can see here we have
character.upper opposite there
python.data
and that will do python is easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the python and the
scripting is very simple
it's when you put the bigger picture
together and starts building these
puzzles and somebody asks you hey i need
the first letter capitalized
unless it's the title and then we have
you start realizing that this can get
really complicated
so numpy just makes it simple and we
like that
and so in this case we did python data
it's all uppercase
python is easy like shouting in your
messenger python is easy
and then if you're ever processing text
and tokenizing it
a lot of times the first thing you do is
we just split the text and we're just
going to
dot run this split are you coming to the
party
if we do that returns an array of each
of the individual words
are you coming to the party splitting it
by the spaces
and then if we're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by
lines and just like we have the basic
split command we also have
split lines hello and you'll see here
the scoop in
for our new line and when we run that if
you're
following the split part with the words
you should see hello
how are you doing the two different
lines are now split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up
commonly used string variable
manipulations
we have strip and in this case we have
nina admin anita and we're going to
strip a off of there
let's see what that looks like and then
you end up with nin diminished it
basically takes up
all leading and trailing letters in this
case we're looking for
a more common would be a space in there
but it might also be punctuation or
anything like that that you need to
remove from your
letters and words and if we're going to
strip and clean data
we also need to be able to reformat it
or join it together
so you see here we have a character join
we'll go ahead and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
these letters up
by the colon and the second one by the
dash
and you can see how this is really
useful if you're processing in this case
a date
we have day month year year month date
very common
things to be have to always switch
around and manipulate depending on what
they're going into what you're working
with
and finally let's look at one last
character string
we're going to do replace if you're
doing misinformation this is good
pulling news articles and replacing
is and what in this case we're just
doing here's a good dancer and we're
going to replace
is with was and you can see here
he was a good dancer hopefully that's
not because he had a bad fall he just
was from like you know 1920s and has
gotten old
so there we go we've covered a lot of
the basics in numpy as far as creating
an array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in
how do we know the shape of it the size
of it what happens we convert it from
a regular integer into a float value
as far as how much space it takes we saw
that that doubled it
item size you have your n dimensions
and probably the most used is shape and
we'll cover more on
shape in part two so make sure you join
us on part two there's a lot of
important things on shaping in there and
setting them up we also saw that you can
create a
zeros based array you can create one
with ones
if we do a range you can see how it is a
lot easier to use to create its own
range or a range as it is in numpy you
saw how easy it was to add two arrays we
saw that earlier
just plus sign then we got into doing
strings
and working with strings and how to
concatenate so if you have two different
arrays of
strings you can bring them together we
also saw how you can fill
so you can add a nice headline dash dash
dash well we saw about capitalize the
first letter we saw about turning it
into a title so all the first letters
are capitalized
doing lower case on all the letters
upper for all the letters just lower and
upper
nice abbreviation we also covered how to
split the character set
how to strip it so if you want to strip
all the a's out from leading ai a's and
ending a's or spaces
you can do that very easily also how to
join the data sets
so here's a character join option for
your strings
and finally we did the character replace
now let's go ahead
and dive in there since we're going
right into part two which is
getting some coding going under our belt
and here in our jupiter notebook we can
go under
new and create a new folder python 3.
i think i forgot to do this last time we
could just do the
control plus plus which in any browser
enlarges the page makes it a lot easier
to see
always a nice feature another beautiful
benefit of using jupyter notebook
and let me go ahead and show you a neat
thing we can do in jupiter this is nice
if you're working with people
and you're doing this as a demo on a
large screen i'm going to do
the hashtag or pound symbol array
manipulation
kind of a title that we're working on
and then i'm going to call this cell
cell type markdown as opposed to code
and you'll see it highlights it here and
then if i run it it just turns it into
array manipulation
and then we're specifically going to be
working on array manipulation
changing shape to start with and we'll
go ahead and mark this cell also a
markdown so it has a nice little look
there and then it comes up and you can
see it just like i said it just
highlights it and makes it very
in bold print just making it easier to
read not a python thing but a jupiter
thing that's good to know about
especially if you're working with the
shareholders since they're investing
money in you
of course the first thing we do is
import we're going to import
numpy as in p and that should be
standard by now
by now you you start a python program
you're doing some data science
numpy is just something you bring in
there and let's go ahead and create
our array and we're going to do that as
the np
dot a range remember that's a 0 where
we're going to do 0 to 9
and then we'll go print a little title
on the original array
we'll just print that array a remember
from the first lesson
so we have our array which is 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8.
and let's add a print space in between
let's create a second array b but we
want this to reshape
array a and what does that mean
and the command is simply reshape and
then we have nine
items in here and this is so important
right now so be very aware
if i did some weird numbers in here it's
not going to work
and we want multiples of 9 we know that
3 times 3 is 9.
so we're going to reshape our a array
by 3x3 and then we're going to print
let's give it a title
oops i have too many brackets in there
modified array
and then let's go ahead and print our b
and let's see what that looks like and
as we come down here you can see we've
taken this and it's gone
from zero one two three four 5 6 7 8
to an array of arrays
and we have 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
and so we split this into 3 by 3. and
you can guess that if i tried to
reshape this let's just do a 5 by 3
which is 15. that's going to give me an
error
so it's not going to work you're not
going to reshape something unless the
shape
all the data in there matches correctly
so we can take this 9
this flat 9 and they call it a flex it's
just a single array
and we can reshape it into a three by
three array
and first you might think matrixes which
this is used for that definitely
i use it a lot in graphing because
they'll come in that i have an array
that's
x y comma x y one white one
comma x two y two and so the shape of it
might be two by the length of the number
of points
and i need to separate that into x flat
ray and a y flat array and you can see
this can be very easy to reshape the
array doing that
and we can of course go back we can do b
do a print and we'll do b dot
latin remember i said it's called a
flatten array and if we run that
you'll see it just goes back to the
original one it takes this 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 and flattens it back to a single
array
and then one other feature to be aware
of is if we
flatten it one of the commands we can
put in there
is order let me just go ahead and do
that order equals
f strangely enough f stands for fortran
the whole fortran days i remember
actually studying fortran programming
language
in this case you'll see that it uses the
first
like 0 3 6 as the order so
instead of flattening it like we had
before 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
it now does 0 3 6 1 4 7
two five eight and if you go to the
numpy array page
you can see here that they have the
flatten and you just open up the numpy
and d array flattened setup
to look it up and they have three
different options they have c
f and a and it's whether to flatten in c
which was based on how the c
code works for flattening originally
worked which is row major
fortran which is column major or
preserve the
column fortran ordering from a so
whatever it was in
the default is the c version so the
default that you saw
you could put orders equal c and you'd
have the same effect as we saw there
before
you could even do order equals a that
would also have the same effect because
that's the default
so really the only other thing you
really need to change on here is to
change it to c if you need it and you
can see right here or f i mean not c
the only thing you really want to change
it to is to your f for the fortron order
which then does it by column versus by
row and let's look at
here we go reshape so let's create a
range of
12 and let's reshape it
and we'll do 4 comma 3 for this one and
remember this is numpy i forgot the np
there
in p dot arrange and we can type in just
a for print or you can do full print a
and of course jupyter notebook even have
a little extra print at the beginning
we run this we'll see we create a nice
array of zero one
two it's reshaped it so we have four
rows
and three columns or you could call it
three columns and four rows
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven
but this one is so important we'll do np
transpose a let's go ahead and run that
and it helps if i get all the s's in
there don't leave an s out
and you'll see here we've taken our
array if you remember correctly we had 0
1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
and we've swapped it so we've gone from
a three by four
or a four by three to a three by four
and this really helps if you're looking
at like a huge
number of rows and the data all comes in
like let's say this is
your features in row one your features
in row two
and this is x y z well when you go to
plot it
you send it all of x in one array all
the white and not one array in all z in
another array
and so it's really important that we can
transpose this rather quickly
this is kind of a fun thing i can
highlight it and do brackets around it
and if you remember correctly
because we're in jupiter it doesn't
matter where we do the print or not
it'll automatically print it for us
and you see if i hit the run button it
comes up at the same exact thing
and let's play with the reshape and you
know what let's zoom this up a little
bit here
make that even bigger so you can really
see what's going on and let's play with
the reshape just a little bit more
we'll do b equals np dot a
range let's do eight
reshape we'll do 2 comma 4.
let's go ahead and print b
and then run that and you'll see we have
now the two rows this is a bit more like
so we have 4
maybe two rows of four things so this
might be all of our x components and our
y
components so we can switch it back and
forth real easy
important to know here whether we do two
comma four or in the case of four comma
three
this has 12 elements and so however you
split it up it's got to equal 12.
so 4 times 3 equals 12 that's pretty
straightforward same thing down here
2 times 4 equals 8. if i change this
let's say i do two comma three let's
just run that in
and you'll find we get an error because
you can't split eight up into two rows
by three
you have to pick something that it can
split up and arrange it in so let's go
ahead and run that
and just for fun let's go
reshape our b again if i can type
reshape our b again and what else goes
into eight well we could do
two by two by two so we can take this
out to three different
dimensions and then of course if we um
because this is going to come out you
you as a
variable we can just go ahead and run it
and it'll print it we can also do a
print statement on there just like we
did before
and you'll see we have two different
groups of two variables
of two different dimensions so two by
two by two
and let's go ahead and assign this to a
variable c equals b reshape
and let's do something a little
different let's roll the axes
roll axes and we'll take our c
and do two comma one and if we go ahead
and run this
it's going to print that out whoops hit
a wrong button there let's do that one
again
and you roll the axis and you can see
that we now have a set of zero one two
three four five six seven we now have
the zero two one three four six
five seven so what's going on here we're
taking and we're rolling the numbers
around and let's just simplify this
we'll just do it with c
comma 1 and run that and so if we roll a
single axis you got 0 1
and then it rolled the 4 5 up and then
we have 2
three six seven and if we do two
let me see what happens there this is
one of those things you really have to
play with and start
filling what it's doing we've now taken
zero
two four six one three five seven so you
can see we've now rolled
by two digits instead of rolling the one
set up we now rolled two digits up there
and so if we go back and we do the one
so we've rolled it up
zero one four five and then we're going
to take the two in there
and we've rolled the 0 1 2 3 4 5 and 6
7. so we start rolling these things
around on here there's a lot of
different things you can do on this
but it's another way to manipulate the
numbers on your
numpy and finally let's go ahead and
swap axes we'll do
c and let's just go ahead and run that
it's going to give me an
error on there that's because it
requires
multiple arguments left out the
arguments so now we can swap and we get
to 0
2 1 3 4 6 5 7.
so you can see everything's been swapped
around
so next thing we want to go over is we
want to go over numpy
arithmetic operations how can we
take these and use these let me just go
ahead and put this cell as a
markdown there we go we'll run that so
it has a nice thing all right
nice title on there that's always
helpful and let's start by creating two
arrays we'll do uh
a as an ep np
range a range nine and let's reshape
this
three by three so by now you should be
saying this reshape stuff and it should
all look pretty familiar
we have our zero one two three four five
six seven eight on there
and let's create a second one b and this
time instead of doing a range let's do n
p
array we'll just create a straight up
array and we'll do an array of three
objects
so it's going to be three by one and if
we go ahead and print
a b out let me run that this is actually
pretty common to have something like
this where you have a
three by whatever it is in a three by
by three array when you're doing your
math you kind of have that kind of setup
on there
and what we can do is we can go um np
dot
add a b don't forget we can always put a
print statement on there
so if we add it you'll see that it just
comes in there and it goes okay we're
adding
10 to everything and we could actually
do something more
i'll make it more interesting 11 10 11
12.
so let's change b's now 10 11 12 and
let's run that
and you can see that we have 10 and then
you had 1
plus 11 is 12 2 plus 12 is 14
13 so 10 plus 3 is 13 11 plus
4 is 15 and 12 plus 5 is 17 and so on
we'll put this back since that's how the
original setup was let's do 10 by 10 by
10
and run that and run that and get the
original answer and if you're going to
add them together
we need to go ahead and subtract a b
and we run that we get minus 10 minus 9
minus 8 just like you would expect
so we have our subtraction 0 minus 10 is
minus 10 and so on and if you're going
to add and subtract you can guess what
the next one is we're going to
multiply and we'll multiply
a b and this should be pretty
straightforward you should expect this
if we multiply 10 times 0 we got 0 10
times 10 is 10 and so on
and finally if you're going to multiply
what's the last one we got is divide
what happens we do divide a by b and we
run this
and we're going to get 0 and this is 0
divided by 10 is 0
1 divided by 10 is 0.1 2 divided by 10
is 0.2 and so on and so on
so the math is pretty straightforward it
just makes it very easy to do the whole
setup and again
if we went this and let's say i'll just
change this up up here instead of 10
we do a hundred and
make this a thousand there we go if we
run that
and then we do the add you can see we
got 10
plus 100 plus a thousand same thing with
the subtract
same thing with the multiply then you
can also see
the same thing here with the divide so a
lot of control there with your array and
your math
again let's set this back to 10 oops
it's right up here
wrong section there we go 10.
we'll just go ahead and run these and
get back to where we were
and this brings us to our next section
which is slicing
and let's put in our just make this a
cell cell type markdown and when we run
that of course it gives us a nice
looking slicing there
and slicing means we're just going to
take sections of the array
so let's create an array in p a range
let's just do 20.
and if you remember if we do a we have a
0 to 19.
and then we can do a and remember you
can always print these this can always
be put in a print but because i'm in
jupiter
if you're doing a demo in jupiter that
is it's just so great that you have all
these controls on here
so we can slice four on and this should
look familiar because this is the same
as the python
and a lot of other different scripting
languages if we do
four go zero one two three that's the
first four
in the thing and the skip sum and starts
with this one
the first four skip then from there on
you can also do the opposite
and go till the fourth one if we run
that we get zero one two three
quite the opposite on there we can do a
single item so we can pick object number
five on the list
run that and 5 happens to be 5 because
that's the order they're in
and then this one's interesting so i can
do s equals
slice and let's create a slice here
and let's do 2 comma 9 comma
let's leave it 2 on there so we'll
create an s slice on here
and then if we take our array and we do
array of s
we're taking our slice in there and
let's go ahead and run that
and let's take a look and see what it
generated here first off we started with
two
so we have two at the beginning we're
gonna end at nine
which happens to be eight so it stops
before the nine
remember when we're doing arrays in
python and then we step
two so two four six eight we could do
this as three
let me run that and you can see how the
changes to five eight
and we could do this as uh let's leave
this at three
and if we change this to ten oops
let's make it twelve there we go when we
run that we have 2 5
8 11. so that's pretty straightforward
it's a very nice feature to have on here
we can
slice it and take different parts of the
series right out of the middle
so now that we've accessed the different
pieces of our array
let's get into iterating iteration and
this is interesting because my sister
who runs a college
data science division the first question
she asks is how do you go through data
and she's asking can you do you know how
to iterate through data do you know how
to do a basic
for loop you know how to go through each
piece of the data and in numpy they have
some cool controls for that
this is a markdown there we go and run
it
and it's called the nd iter i'm not sure
what the nd stands for
but ndeiter for iterator so before we do
that though let's create an array or
something we can actually iterate
through
we'll call it a equals np
a range let's do something a little
funny here or funky
and we'll do 0 45 5.
i'm not sure why the guys in the back
picked this particular one was kind of a
fun one
and if i run that we do this you can see
we get 0 5
10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
that's what this array looks like and
that's just from our slice you could
this is just a slice that's all that is
is we created a slice of zero forty five
zero to forty five step five and so we
can do with this we can also do a equals
the shape let's go ahead and take and
reshape this
and since there's nine variables in
there we'll do a reshape it three by
three
so if we run that whoops missed
something there
that is the a that really helps
so if we do the a reshape and we'll go
ahead and print that out
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35
40. and then we simply do four
x in our numpy and d
enter of a
colon and we'll just go ahead and print
x and let's see what happens here when
we run through this and we print
each one of those it goes all the way
through the whole array so it's the same
thing we just saw before we got 0
5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
so it prints out each object in the
array so you can go through and view
each one of these
and certainly if you remember you could
also flatten the array and just do for
a and that also and get the same result
there's a lot of ways to do this
but this is the proper way with the nd
iterator because it'll
minimize the amount of resources needed
to go through each of the different
objects in the numpy array and
hopefully you asked this question i just
did that
and the question is how can i change
this instead of doing each
object so first of all let's go ahead
and take my cell type and
mark that down and run it and so we're
going to work on iteration order
c style and f style remember c because
it came from the c programming
and f because it came from the old
fortran programming
so let's give us a reminder i will do a
print a
and we'll do four x in np
iterate a but we also want to do this
in a specific order and you know what
i'm a really lazy typer so let's go back
up here
this is the nd iterator i knew i was
missing the nd part of
a let's do order equals
c we'll print x on there and let's do
that again
and this time order
order equals f
there we go order equals f let's go
ahead and run this
and see what happens here and the first
thing you're going to notice
our original array 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35
40. when we do order c that's the
default
0 5 10 15 20 and so on and then when you
come down
here you'll see f order f
is 0 15 30. so it takes the first digit
of each
on the subarrays or the second dimension
and then it goes into the second one 5
20 35 10 25 40. so slightly different
order for iterating through it if you
need to do that
so we've covered reshaping we've covered
math we've covered iteration
we've covered a number of things the
next section we want to go ahead and go
over
is going to be joining arrays so we need
to bring them together let me go ahead
and take the cell
and make it a markdown cell
type markdown there we go and run that
so let's work on joining arrays
so we can bring them together and with
different options we have
and let's do we'll do an np array one
two
comma three four we'll go ahead and
print
let's do oops first
these rays aren't that big so let's just
go ahead and keep it all on one line
a so if we run this
first array one two three four oops i
forgot that it automatically wraps it
when you do it this way
so we'll go ahead and keep it separate
and print
a there we go and let's go ahead and do
a b
and we'll do five six seven eight and
notice i'm keeping the same shape on
these two arrays
depending on what you're doing those
shapes have to match
let's go ahead and print
second array
do a print b i'm going to run that
oops missed something up there let me
fix that real quick
when i was reformatting it to go on
separate lines i messed that up there we
go run
all right so we have first array one two
three four second array five
six seven eight and we'll put a carriage
return on there
and the keyword we use is um concatenate
and if you're familiar with linux it
usually means you're adding it to the
end
on there and we're gonna do what they
call a long axis
zero so we have concatenate a b along
axis zero
let's go ahead and run that and see what
that looks like so we have one two
three four five six seven eight so now
we have
an array that is four by two as a nice
shape of four by two one here
and if we're going to do it along the
axis zero
you should guess what the next one is
we're gonna do it along the
one axis and let's see how those differ
from each other let's just go ahead and
run that
and again all we're doing is adding in
the axis equals
one so we have our concatenate we have a
b
and then axis one remember a couple
things one these are the same shape
so we have a two by two same dimensions
going in there
you're going to get an error if you're
concatenating and they're not
if you have something that instead of
one two is one two three
four five six with a five six seven
eight they'll give you an error on there
in fact let's take a look and see what
happens when we do that
let me just take this one two three
three four five and let's run that and
if we come down here oh we got there
it says all the input array dimensions
except for the concatenation axes
m must match exactly so it'll let you
know if you mess up
that's always a good thing let's go
ahead and take this back here
and let's go ahead and run that and so
we have our zero axes which is one two
three four five six seven eight and we
bring them together
and you'll see a very different set up
here when we do it along the
axis one we end up with instead of
a four by two we end up with a two by
four one two five six three four seven
eight
and that's just changing which axes
we're going to go ahead and concatenate
on
what i find is when you're talking about
the concatenate or the
joining arrays you really got to play
with these for a while to make sure you
understand what you mean by the axes
it looks very intuitive when you're
looking at it actually zero
one two three four five six seven eight
axes one is then
splitting in a different way one two
five six three four seven eight
when you're actually using real data you
start to really get a feel for what this
means and what this does
so if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and look at splitting the array
and do that in the markdown and run it
there we go so you have a nice little
title there
and we'll go ahead and create an array
of nine
let's do np split we'll do
a and we're gonna split it by three
let's just see what that looks like so
if we split it we get an array zero one
two
three four five we get three separate
arrays on here and remember we're
looking at
let me just print a up here so we're
looking at zero one two three four five
six seven eight and then we can split it
into three separate arrays
and let's take this we're going to do
this right down here just move the a
split down here
instead of the 3 let's do 4 comma 5.
put that in brackets and so we do it
this way
we have 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8. and that's kind of interesting
i wasn't sure
what to expect on that but we get when
you split an a by 4 comma
5 you get a totally different setup on
here as far as the way it split the
array
and to understand how this works i'm
going to change the 5
to a 7 and this will visually make this
a little bit more
clear so we had four and five it went
zero one two
three four five six seven eight
and you see the markers four and five
when we do
four and seven i get zero one two three
four
five six seven eight and so
what you're looking at here is the first
markers this is going to go to four
so there's our first split at the four
the marker of four
and then the second split is going to be
at position seven and this is the same
thing here
four position five that's why we're
splitting it in those two sections
we could also do it seven let's just see
what that looks like run
and you can see i now have zero one two
three four
five six seven eight so we can split in
all kinds of different ways and create a
different set of
multiple arrays on here and split it all
kinds of different ways
and before we get into the graphs and
other
miscellaneous stuff let's go ahead and
look
at resizing the array i'm going to take
this cell
and set the cells a mark down and run it
give us a nice title there and we'll do
an array
uh an input array of one two three and
four
five six here let's go and just print
let's go print a dot
shape and we'll go ahead and run that
whoops hit a wrong button there
hit the comma instead of the dot so we
have a shape of two comma three here
and this is important to note because we
start resizing it it's going to mess
with different aspects of the shape
and so we'll go ahead and do a print
scoop in for a blank line there we go
let's do b
equals np dot resize
we're going to resize a and let's resize
it with
three by two and then we'll just go
ahead and
print b and print
b period shape not a comma
i'll run that oops forgot the
quotation marks around the end we'll go
ahead and run that
and let's just see what that looks like
so we have
one two three four five six original
array with a shape of two
three and then we want to go ahead and
resize it by 3
2 and we end up with 1 2 3
4 5 6 and we end up with a shape of 3
2. that shouldn't be too much of a
surprise
you know we got 6 elements in there we
can resize it by two
three was the original one and then
we're actually just reshaping is how
that kind of comes out as when you
resize it like that
but what happens if we do something a
little different
and let's go ahead and just take this
whole thing and copy it down here so you
can see what that looks like
and instead of doing 3 2 remember last
time
i did the um to reshape it i messed with
the numbers and it gave me an
error when you resize it you don't have
to match the numbers they don't have to
be the same dimensions
so we can instead of going from a 2 3 to
a 3 2
we can resize it to a 3 3. so let's take
a look and see how it handles that
and we come down here to 3 3 we end up
with
one two three four five six and it
repeats
one two three so it actually takes the
data and just adds a whole other block
in there based on the original data
and repeating it all right now at this
point
you know we've been looking at tons of
numbers and moving stuff around
we want to go ahead and do is get a
little visual here because that
certainly you can picture all the
different numbers on there
but let's look at histogram let's put
this into a histogram
let me go ahead and run that and to do
that we're going to use the matte
plot library so from map plot library
we're going to import
pi as plt that's usually the notation
you see for pipelot
so if you ever see plt in a code it's
probably pi plot in the matplot library
and then the guys in the back did a nice
job and gals too
guys and gals back there our team over
at simply learn put together a nice
array for me
20 87 4 40 53 with a bunch of numbers
that way we had something to play with
and what we want to do is we want to do
plot
the histogram remember a histogram says
how many times
different numbers come in and then we're
going to put them in bins
and we have been 0 to 20 to 40 to 60 to
80 to 100.
you might in here with the matplot
library they call them
bins you might hear the term buckets
where they put them in buckets that's a
really common term
then we want to give it a title so the
way it works is you do your plt.hist for
histogram
your plt title and your plt show
and we're doing just a single array in
here in the
numpy array of a and let's go ahead and
run this piece of code
taking a moment to come out there's this
figure size so it's generating the graph
and you can see we have and let's just
take a look at this and go down a size
there we go okay so now we can see we're
taking a look at here so between
0 and 20 we have three values so we have
a 20 here
we have a 4 and a 11 and a 15.
0 1 2 3. it's actually four values
but they start at zeros remember we
always count from 0
up and from 20 to 40 we got
20 this is 1 42
3 4 5
6. and so you can see in the histogram
it shows that the most common numbers
coming up
is going to be between the 40 and 60
range least common between the 80 and
100
this looks like a age demographics is
what this looks like to me
and you can see where they would have
put it in the buckets of different age
groups which would be a nice way of
looking at this
histograms are so important so powerful
when you're doing demos and explaining
your data
so being able to quickly put a histogram
up that shows
what's common and how it's trending is
really important
and using that with a numpy is really
easy
and you know what let's take the same
data and i want to show you why we do
bins or why we have buckets of data i'm
used to calling it buckets
why we have bins let's do it instead of
by 20
let's do it by tens and see what happens
and what happens when you do it by tens
is you miss out on the
you can see a nice curve here on the
first one and on the second one it looks
like a ladder going up and a plummet a
ladder going up and a plummet and a
ladder going down
so the first would be more indicative of
an age group and the second one would be
what you would get if you divide it
incorrectly
you wouldn't see the natural trend of
i don't know what this would be maybe
how much food they eat
hopefully not because i'm in 50 so i'm
right in the middle there that which
means i get a ton of food compared to
everybody else
but it's some kind of democrat maybe
it's mental maybe it's knowledge because
we we hit a certain
point and we start losing our marbles
start leaking out or something so you
start off
knowing something and then as you get
older you grow more but you see here we
lose that you lose that continuity in
the
thing if you split the histogram into
too many bins or too many buckets
and if you actually plotted this by the
individual numbers it would just be a
bunch of dots
on the graph it wouldn't mean a whole
lot
and we've looked at graphs there are
terms that are a ton
of useful functions in numpy i'm sure
there's even new ones that
are going to be in here but let's just
cover some important ones you really
need to know about
if you're using the numpy framework one
of them is line space function
this is generating data so we have a
line space we have 1
3 10 and when we do that we end up
with 10 numbers so if you count them
there's 10 numbers
they're between 1 and 3 and they're
evenly spaced we get one one point two
two two
but these are all there's a total of ten
here and it's right between the one and
three range
that can be there's a lot of uses for
that but they're probably more obscure
than a lot of the other common
numpy array set up a real
common one is to do summation so we'll
do
summation where you do in this case we
create a numpy array of one
of two different arrays one two three or
two different dimensions one two three
three four five
and we're going to sum them up under
axes zero which is your columns
and if you remember correctly columns is
the one plus three
two plus four three plus five so we have
three columns
and if we change this we'll just flip
this to one
we get two numbers so we get one two
three all added together
which equals six and three plus four
plus five which equals twelve
we'll set this back to zero
there we go since this is we're looking
to actually zero
and these probably could have been some
of these communities our math
section square root and standard
deviation
two very important tools we use
throughout the machine learning process
in data science and simply we take the
np array we have
again the one two three four five six
three four five i don't know why i need
to keep recreating it probably could
just kept it
but we can take the square root of a so
it goes through and it takes the square
root of all the different terms in a
and we can also take the standard
deviation how much they deviate
in value on there and there's a rabble
function we can run that
and in p array as x we're going to do x
equals say we changed it from a to x
x equals ravel and this sets it up as
columns so we have one two three four
five this is all columns on here
very similar to the flattened function
so they kind of look
almost identical but we also have the
option of doing a ravel by column
and then another one is log so you can
do mathematical log on your array in
this case we have
one two three and we'll find the log
base 10 for each of those three numbers
there's a couple of them they don't you
can't just do any number here after log
but there is also log base 2.
log base 10 is pretty commonly used on
here
there we go before we go let's have a
little fun
let's do a little practice session here
on some more
challenging questions so you start to
think how this stuff fits together
right now we just looked at all the
basics and all the basic tools you have
so let's do some numpy practice examples
and let's start by figuring out
how do you plot say a sine wave in numpy
how what would that look like
and so in this project we wouldn't have
to do this because i've already run
these but we'd want to go ahead
and import our numpy as np and import
our matplot library pipeline as plt
so we get our tools going here and then
we'll break it into two
sections because we need our x y
coordinates in here
so first off let's create our x
coordinates
and our x coordinates we're going to set
to an a range
and we want this error a range since
we're doing
sine and cosine it's going to be between
0 and 0.1
and then we use our np and we actually
can look up numpy
stores pi so you have the option just
pulling pi in there directly from numpy
it has a few other variables that it
stores in there
that you can pull from there but we have
numpy pi and we generate a nice range
here
let's go ahead and run this and just out
of curiosity let's see what x looks like
i always like to do that so we have
0.1.2.3.4
so we're going 0 to
in this case point four three times
numpy pi
remember pi is like three point
something something something so that
makes sense it should be about nine
and we're doing intervals of 0.1 so we
create a nice range of data
and then we need to create our y
variable and so
y is going to simply equal np our numpy
dot sine
of x and then once we have our x and y
and if we print let's go and just print
y
see how that we'll do this let's do this
so it looks print
x print y so we basically have
two arrays of data so we have like our x
axes and our y axes going on there
and this is simply a plt dot plot
because we're going to plot the points
and we'll do x
comma y and then we want to actually see
the graph so we'll do plot
dot show and we'll go ahead and run that
and you see we get a nice sine wave and
here's our number
zero through nine and here's our sine
value which oscillates between minus one
and one like we expected to
then for the next challenge let's create
a six by six
two dimensional array and let one and
zero be placed
alternatively across the diagonals
oh that's a little confusing so let's
think about that we're going to create a
six by six
two dimensional so the shape is six by
six two dimensional array
and let one and zero be placed
alternatively across the diagonals
now if you remember from lesson one we
can fill a whole
numpy array with zeros or ones or
whatever
so we're going to do np or create a
numpy zeros
and we're gonna do a six by six and
we'll go ahead and make sure it knows
it's an
integer even though it's usually the
default and just real quick let's take a
look and see what that looks like so if
i run this
you can see i get six by six grid so
six by six zero zero zero zero zero
now if i understand this correctly when
they say ones and zero placed
alternatively across the diagonals
they want the center diagonal maybe
that's going to stay zero
all the way down and then the next
diagonal will be ones
all the way across diagonally and then
the next one zeros the next one
ones the next one zeros and so on
hopefully you can see my mouse lit up
there and highlighting it
so let's take a little piece of code
here and we'll do
z one colon colon two comma colon colon
two
equals one and wow that's a mouthful
right there so let's go ahead and run
this and see what that's doing
and so what we're doing is we're saying
hey let's look at
in this case row one there's one and
then we're going to go
every other row two so we're going to
skip a row so
skip here skip here skip here so we're
going down
this way and we're going every other row
going
this way it's hard to highlight columns
so you can see right here where the that
we're not touching each row
like this row right here is not being
touched okay so we're going to start
with row one
and then we're going to skip a row and
another one and so we're going every two
rows
and then in every two rows we're looking
at every two
starting with the beginning that's what
this thing blank means
so we're going to start with the
beginning and we're going to look at all
of them but we're going to skip every
two
so starting with row one
we look at all the rows but we do we
do it by two steps so we go one skip one
uh you know one
skip one one skip one one if you left
this out and do every one this would
just be ones in fact let's see what this
looks like if i go like this
and run it you can see that i guess get
ones
so this notation allows us to go down
each row row by row and we're going to
do every other row
set up on there and so if we're going to
start with row one
we also control z
try that there we go we'll start with
row zero
again we're going to go each row step
two so we'll start with row zero
and we'll go every other row and this
time we'll start with one
column one and again we go every other
one
going down step that's where that step
two is
skipping every other one we're gonna set
that equal to one so let's see what that
looks like
and you can see here we get our answer
we get zero one zero zero
but it has the ones going in diagonals
on every other diagonal and zero on
every other one
a little bit of a brain teaser that one
trying to get that one to work out
so you can see how you can arrange your
rows and here's your step
and your different axis on there
and then the next one is find the total
number and locations of missing values
in the array the first challenge is to
create
some missing numbers so let's create our
ray z
we're going to do uh numpy dot
random.rand
10 comma 10. and before we do the second
part let me just take the second part
out
and let's just see what that looks like
so let's run that
and there we go so we have a 10 by 10
random array
it randomly is picking out numbers and
next we want to go ahead and take our
random integer size equals 5
and then we're going to do a random
random 10 size equals 5.
so in the z we're going to select a
number of random spaces here
and set them equal to null value
and let's go ahead and run that so you
can see what that looks like
and if we look at the array we've
created one
two three four
there should be a fifth one in here my
eyes may be filling me
so we've created a series of oh because
zero zero to
five zero one two three four so we got f
there are
different null values on here and
this is kind of a neat notation to
notice that we can generate
random integers size equals five so this
generates
five by five miniature grid inside of
this to tell it where to put the nands
at so that's kind of a cool little thing
you can do
and then we want to look up and see how
many null values are in there
and this is simply just np is nan of z
simple so if it is none then we want to
sum it up so we're going to sum up
all of the different null values on
there now let's do one one more feature
in here which is really cool
let's go ahead and print the indexes so
np
arguer np is nan of z
so we're going to create our own another
np array and let's run this
and we'll see here that comes up with
the four indexes so we did count four of
them up there
it tells you where they are one nine two
zero four six
five four and then let's go ahead and
run this again
run run there we go this time i got five
that's what get for random numbers
another fun one that i always like to do
it's very similar because we have np
is non-z dot sums we're summing the
number of
nands and we can get the indexes and you
can reshape the indexes
but you can also just do we'll do an
inds
where np is nan of z
and let's just print let's print that
print inds let's see what that looks
like
and it's very similar we have we have
zero one three zero six three eight six
nine three
but i've split it into two different
arrays so we have our x
and our y kind of coordinates going
there and what i can now
do is i can now do z i
and ds equals and at this point
you can also instead of getting the sum
you can get the means
or the all the numbers and that kind of
thing or
the average as it is so that'd be one
thing you could do and you could pick up
the average
that's very common in data science to
get the average and just use that for a
value
we'll go and just set it to zero and
then let's go ahead and print
our z and run that
and you can see we come down here we
have
wherever there was a null value it is
now zero
and you can set this to whatever you
want this is another way to replace data
or help clean data
depending on what it is you're doing so
wow we covered a lot of stuff
so quick rehash going over everything we
went into there we looked at
array manipulation changing the shape
how to switch that around we even had
the flattened down there which remember
we have another command
lower that's similar we could change the
order by f
remember f stands for fortran very
strange connotation but there's c and f
c is the standard and f switches it to a
different order
to be honest i usually have to look it
up because i almost never use
f but when you need it you're like oh my
gosh it was the other order
just do a quick google so we talked
about reshape making sure that the
dimensions are the same
you don't want to have like something
that has 12 objects in it and reshape it
to
see 11 and 5 because it doesn't work it
doesn't divide into 12.
we can transpose so we can switch them
so we can go from
a four by three to a three by four oops
i did the other way around
three by four to four by three
we covered reshaping the array we did
the roll the axes you can do some weird
things with swapping and rolling axes
and transposing the numbers
we dug a little bit into the arithmetic
so we talked about
adding we talked about subtracting
multiplying dividing
and you know at this point it's so
important we just look up the
numpy mathematics and you can see here
they have just about everything
your trigonometry uh your hyperbolic
functions
roundings sums products differences
there are so many all your different
miscellaneous mathematical connotations
so
you know google it go to the main numpy
page and look at the different setups
you can do on there
so we covered that and we did slicing
how to break it apart we did iterating
over the array
we covered joining arrays and how to
concatenate
remember concatenate just means add on
to it so in this
case how are you adding b onto a is how
you'd read that
from linux you should catch the
concatenate because that's used
regularly there
splitting the array we talked about how
to split the array in different ways so
you can split it
in array of arrays all kinds of
different ways to split the array up
how to resize it and remember resize
does not
have to have the same shape but if you
resize it
it will take the data and begin at the
beginning and add new rows on if the
size is bigger if it's smaller it
truncates it it just cuts the end off
we looked at how to do a histogram and
how to plot that
we mentioned buckets or bins as they
call them in
pipelot and then we covered a lot of
other useful functions
in numpy talked about the line space
setup for
doing numbers in a series
how to sum the axes up again that's part
of the mathematical formulas there that
we looked at there's a
sum there's also means and median all of
those you can compute in numpy
and you can also do the square root and
standard deviation
the ravel function very similar to the
flat
to be honest i almost always just use
the flat but you know the revel
has its own kind of functionality that
it does and then we went into some numpy
practice examples
we challenged you to create a sine wave
in numpy and how to do that
we're kind of looking for that a range
remember how we do the a range and you
can
have your beginning value your n value
which they did is three times
pi number pi and we're going to do
intervals of 0.1
and then y just equals the numpy sign of
x there's our math from the math page we
were just looking at remember that it's
right at the top
and finally we went down here we had
this kind of a little brain teaser how
to do diagonal zeros and ones
playing with the different connotations
of z of the numpy array
and then we did a random size and we
played a little bit
with how to with the null values playing
with null values
if you're doing any data science you
know null values are like a headache
what do you do with them big sets of
data you get rid of them small debt
sets of data you have to factor
something in there like figure out the
average or the
median there and then replace it with
that so
with that we want to go and wrap this up
and i want to thank you for joining me
today
again my name is richard kirschner with
the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead and if you do
have additional
questions feel free to come visit us on
our website or post some questions down
in the youtube video
and we'll follow up with you again thank
you for joining us
and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here